Just. It's so weird.
It's so weird what we're doing.
I've never had this little information
going into any situation in my entire life.
We don't know one of their.
Anything about my guy.
We know nothing.
We don't know his name.
We don't know what he looks like.
We don't know anything about it.
It's true. This is so odd.
It's very black cat,
golden retriever.
Fully pink. Liz read one comment that said that and has really,
like, really stuck to this. Yeah,
black cat, golden retriever thing.
But that's what a black cat would say.
Like, you're. You being annoyed?
It sounds racist. No.
We're gonna have so much fun.
We're probably gonna be together.
I have parts,
but some of my worst parts come out when I'm with you. In a safe way.
Like in a sisterly way.
This will be so much more fun.
Well, if it starts sucking,
we'll just talk. Exactly.
I want to buy merch.
I just remember this night.
Just left the date.
It's like, slowly.
How was it?
You guys are gonna have to listen to the episode to hear how it went.